Shit does happen,
but you know what?
Still maybe Brazil was like slow the fuck down with these goddamn movies,
but they do have the biggest rain forest in the world and they do this gay shit
fucking Amazon for.
It's crazy.
I couldn't be,
I was a text Tim Kenny and I say I can't be when he's talking about all of those
Nazis.
What Duff Farese is that in Dina?
They flew from Germany to fucking Argentina.
That's a true story until I text him too.
I went,
Dude,
you did the greatest promo ever for your discovery and history channel show
cause I really was.
I love Tim,
but I don't watch that much TV with that,
with that stuff.
He was talking about those Germans that live in Argentina.
How many cities?
How many villages?
No,
but hundreds of thousands.
100,000 and you go to the village.
This is an term and it's all German.
The architecture,
we go into the house,
it's all fucking images of it,
Jamie.
They don't speak out there fucking lick of Spanish.
They were a leader hose in that drink and giant steins.
They're proud of their history.
Yeah.
That's what's creepy about he goes,
do you know what built that land?
Juice.
Fucking the,
their,
their cavity to fillings.
Third Wedding rings.
That's what built that.
I got so upset man.
And then he's talking about how have they would torture kids.
I just heard,
I stopped listening at that.
You sit there while he was talking about how Mengele and a lot of the SS
soldiers went to Argentina and continued a lot of their torture experiments and
that they had met some of the people that had been tortured by these ss guys.
Horrific,
horrific young boy.
They break their bones,
bring her son back to health,
set him on fire.
Just the worst shit you can imagine just to see like what they could do.
I went to Argentina like 10 years ago and I swear,
I swear to God,
I've never been to a country with so many beautiful women really believe will
say no more.
It's like there's,
you see like 10 at a time,
13 head,
they're like everywhere.
And you would think you would think it would be easy,
uh,
to pick him up.
But it's super hard because they have no faith in men because the men,
they're like prostitution.
Yeah.
They know that there's no reason for a guy to,
to get committed so they don't trust guys.
So they're like,
just,
uh,
that was my experience.
You just like hang out.
They hang out with each other and they just cock block each wild wiener.
Hey,
travel cock block each other.
They travel in packs,
they're everywhere.
It's incredible.
Plus touch of God,
I'd love to go to Argentina.
You,
you watch this.
It's,
it's crazy man.
And,
and Tim said he would go there and you know,
they're,
they're like so,
so proud of their Nazi grandfather and stuff like that.
And Tim's like,
what the fuck,
man,
that's crazy.
Crazy.
No,
no,
no.
Not a lick of Spanish anywhere.
And Hitler maybe,
uh,
you know,
yeah,
that's,
Joe asked him,
he goes,
if you have to decide right now,
did Hitler die in that bin?
And like history tells you,
and this is Tim Kennedy,
is there a total line his life?
He goes,
nope,
history's wrong on this one day.
And he'd be so happy about what that history's wrong.
History is often wrong.
That's what I'm saying is drink.
Kennedy approves it.
It's working.
We go and sizzler.
Two K's never told a lie to sizzler.
Tip Guineas never told a lie in his life.
Are you sure?
No,
dude.
Tim Kidneys is,
I mean,
he's as American pies it gets,
yeah.
I love that guy,
man.
I cried because I thought he's going to die one time.
I love him.
Yeah.
He doesn't have a crazy show that he,
where he tries to kill himself.
They try to kill him.
Like what's the name of that show?
Uh,
what's it called?
It's like some show where someone almost died.
It was in Atlanta and jumps out of plane.
Yes.
Oh,
you a bull fighting hard to,
hard to kill Tim Canada Ham.
That's how Steven Seagal movie,
isn't it?
Yeah,
it is terrible movie.
Although as a fan,
as a kid,
but yet,
and then he also has hunting Hitler on the history.